[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans un paris saclay
et tv ensoleillé justement je vous
invite à vous balader dans ce quartier
de l'école polytechnique pour découvrir
les différents écosystèmes qui structure
le paysage le pea paris saclay a mise en
place des panneaux pédagogiques comme
celui ci pour mieux comprendre ce qui se
joue dans ces espaces naturels et pour
nous rappeler qu'il faut les préserver
il est aujourd'hui à la tête d'ivalua
une société qui est né ici sur votre
territoire
david tua d'huy a commencé à
gif-sur-yvette avant de se développer à
l'international
un parcours une expérience qu'il veut
partager et ça tombe bien c'est lui le
parrain de ce prime 50 cette année c'est
un concours je vous le savez qui est
donc organisée pour les startups local
c'est l'un des temps forts du paris
saclay spring qui se tient les 12 et 13
mai enfin un festival un festival de
musique le festival être l'hôte d'un
événement international
une vingtaine d'artistes venus du monde
entier se retrouvent ici à paris saclay
ils vont partager leurs répertoires et
nous proposer une série de concerts et
parmi les autres événements à ne pas
rater et bien il y a beaucoup de
manifestations culturelles pour les
semaines à venir vous verrez tout ça
dans notre agenda
vous les avez peut-être remarqué en vous
baladant c'est panneaux pédagogiques
vous permettent de mieux comprendre les
différents écosystèmes de votre
territoire il y en a plusieurs
disséminés dans le quartier de l'école
polytechnique et celui ci par exemple
nous explique que c'est une zone humide
et on peut aussi comprendre la faune la
flore qui donc se développe ici alors
cette opération de sensibilisation
elle a été voulu par le père paris
saclay elle a été mise en place avec
confluence et vous l'avez compris
l'objectif c'est d'informer de
sensibiliser pour mieux préserver ces
espaces naturels
[Musique]
le pea paris-saclay mis en place neuf
panneaux pédagogiques soient les acquis
du quartier de l'école polytechnique et
d'autant de lille ces panneaux ont été
déployés dans le cadre de la stratégie
rse développement durable de l'eau pea
et ils ont été conçus par le bureau
d'études confluence avec l'aide du
comité scientifique
le but de ces panneaux est de
sensibiliser les riverains aux enjeux
écologiques des différents écosystèmes
qui ont fait préservés ou créés dans le
cadre de l'aménagement des actions qui
ces panneaux pourront être le support de
balades pédagogiques visant à découvrir
et comprendre le fonctionnement de ces
écosystèmes qui structure le paysage
[Musique]
ces panneaux pédagogiques ils ont été
réalisées à la demande de le paix à
paris saclay ils sont issus du constat
que lors des inventaires qu'on réalise
sur les secteurs les aménagements qui
ont été réalisés dans le cadre des axes
attirent une faune et une flore qui
commence à être relativement
intéressante et diversifiée et en
parallèle c'est aussi des quartiers qui
se peuple qui commence à être fréquenté
pour l'observation pour la balade donc
il y avait un intérêt à faire connaître
l'intérêt de ces milieux et de
comprendre comment est-ce qu'ils ont été
organisées pour les gens qui commencent
à fréquenter régulièrement ou moins
régulièrement le quartier
on essaye de balayer un petit peu toutes
les thématiques et accompagner
une déambulation dans ces secteurs
naturels des ac par une continuation par
ces panneaux qui permettent
d'accompagner cette cette balade
et sont également liés au fait qu' un
certain nombre de naturalistes
observateurs
par exemple ceux qui font partie du
comité scientifique
observe que ces milieux naturels qui ont
besoin de quiétude parce que ces espèces
qui sont relativement sensible des
rangements elles ont besoin d'être
respectés dans leur tranquillité et que
ces espaces parce qu'ils étaient mal
compris et est aussi fréquentée par des
promeneurs par des chiens et deux chats
compromettait leurs leur intérêt donc la
volonté de l'établissement public
paris-saclay c'était d'accompagner par
la pédagogie la découverte de ces
milieux pour ça ce soit des milieux
attractif mais qui préserve aussi lee
burke et une pour que les espèces
sauvages qui s'y installent il reste
malgré le développement du quartier
[Musique]
tout a commencé à gif sur yvette et
depuis sa société ivalua se déploie dans
le monde entier 17 bureaux à
l'international et un siège social à
massy david tua d'hui est le parrain de
spring 50 ce concours ouvert aux
start-up locales et qui se déroule dans
le cadre de paris saclay spring cette
édition 2022 est très attendue elle se
déroulera les 12 et 13 mai est le
parrain de spring 50 est ravie d'y
participer rencontre
bonjour je m'appelle david conduis je
suis le président et fondateur de la
société ivalua donc il va lui avec une
solution en mode saas
solutions logicielles pour gérer les
achats pour les grandes entreprises
notre but principal c'est d'aider ces
grandes entreprises à gérer l'ensemble
de tous leurs types d'achats et de
pouvoir collaborer avec l'ensemble de
tous leurs fournisseurs en temps réel et
de façon optimisée
on est localisée sur plus de 17 bureaux
au travers du monde notre siège social
se trouve à massique dans la zone paris
saclay nous sommes dans une forte
croissance depuis pas mal d'années plus
de 30 % de croissance sur ces dernières
années notre ambition c'est d'être
l'acteur majeur sur ce marché qui est un
très grand marché le marché des gestions
de la gestion des achats pour les
entreprises c'est un grand marché de
plus de 50 milliards de en termes de
taille de marché
je suis ravi d'avoir été invité à être
le parrain de la nouvelle édition
de spring paris saclay pour moi c'est un
un vrai bonheur de pouvoir être ses
parrains pour pouvoir apporter
l'expérience que j'ai d'avoir créé la
société il ya maintenant plus de 20 ans
en démarrant de chez moi à
gif-sur-yvette ensuite on s'est installé
dans la pépinière d'entreprises de
courcelles sur yvette qui est aussi dans
la zone et puis ensuite nous avons
déménagé à orsay et là tout récemment
nous venons d'un plate et notre siège
mondial à massy dans la zone atlantis
donc vraiment j'ai baigné dans cette
dans cette région je dirais même que
personnellement j'ai aussi un
attachement fort ce que j'ai fait
l'école polytechnique et ensuite j'ai
poursuivi en faisant une thèse de
mathématiques et notamment en
travaillant à l'université paris-sud
orsay et puis aussi à l'institut de
physique nucléaire je suis du coup ravi
de parrainer cette nouvelle édition de
voir éclore toutes ces start-up de
pouvoir les aider du mieux que je peux
en apportant l'expérience que j'ai sur
ben plus dans le domaine de l'édition de
logiciels saas mais aussi de la
croissance d'entreprises de la levée de
fonds de pouvoir grandir à
l'international ils seraient ravis
d'apporter cette expérience à toutes les
start up qui vont se présenter dans
cette nouvelle édition
[Musique]
ils viennent du chili du danemark du
portugal et de bien d'autres pays une
vingtaine de musiciens participent au
festival est no ils vont passer dix
jours ensemble ils vont partager leurs
répertoires apprendre à se connaître et
surtout nous donner une série de
concerts nous avons rencontré ces
artistes
je
de plus le 1er mars la mjc boby-lapointe
organise un rassemblement de jeunes
musiciens qui s'appelle et nos france
ce rassemblement a pour objectif
l'échangé le partage des musiques
traditionnelles des participants donc ce
sont 25 jeunes qui viennent d'un peu
partout dans le monde qui viennent je
crois aller plus loin de l'inde et du
chili
sur le continent américain
pendant cinq jours ils ont travaillé
échanges et préparer un concert est là
aujourd'hui et demain ils vont aller à
la rencontre des habitants du territoire
ou dans les écoles comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
ils vont aussi voir des résidences
personnes âgées les pattes de villebon
au collège enfin voilà ils vont un peu
partout dans les centres sociaux de
palaiseau et
maisons de quartier et donc ils vont par
petits groupes échanger avec le public
[Musique]
après ces jours de préparation des
changes de partage et de rencontre par
petits groupes des habitants du
territoire paris saclay et les jeunes
musiciens feront trois concerts donc 3
conserve tout public et deux concerts
scolaires pour finir ce rassemblement de
jeunes musiciens
nous ça fait dix ans qu'on organise ce
rassemblement de jeunes musiciens
la mjc ville montre énormément sur la
musique et ça il ya un plus quand on
fait ce genre de
deux rassemblements c'est parce que
c'est il ya des d'autres cultures qui
viennent chez nous qu'ils partagent donc
ça met en mouvement un peu sur sur
d'autres esthétiques que celle que nous
faisons au tour de plus tôt de musiques
actuelles et du jazz donc de travailler
là avec sur ces esthétiques à de musique
traditionnelle au niveau du monde c'est
très enrichissant pour pour les
musiciens de la mjc mais aussi du
territoire puisque on va aussi sur le
territoire
[Applaudissements]
et voilà pour l'actualité de votre
territoire place maintenant au grand
rendez vous à ne pas rater dans les
semaines qui viennent nous vous avons
présenté le parrain de spring 50
n'hésitez pas à participer à ce concours
qui distingue 50 start up de paris
saclay l'appel à candidatures est lancé
alors attention la clôture des
inscriptions c'est le 10 mars il suffit
de cliquer sur le lien que vous voyez
apparaître sur votre écran pour les
gourmands ne ratez pas le marché des
producteurs locaux c'est le 19 mars à
gif-sur-yvette ses coordonnées par là
même local qu'on ne présente plus à leur
programme le manège noir dès 11 heures
et toute la journée la fanfare la bande
à joe c'est la fanfare de centrale
supélec et on en parlait il ya quelques
minutes seulement l'orque est éphémère
et nos france sera sur l'agglomération
paris saclay c'est du 1er mars au 13
mars si vous êtes plutôt électro ne
ratez pas la 6e édition du festival
électro chic le voilà de retour donc à
versailles et dans sept autres villes de
versailles grand parc il ya des concerts
évidemment notamment dans la magnifique
nef de l'école d'architecturé et aussi
des surprises et des ateliers pour les
ados si vous aimez la poésie alors
attention attention c'est le printemps
des poètes et c'est du 12 au 26 mars un
événement national la commanderie vous
propose des rendez vous avec la poésie
lectures rencontres spectacles
expositions ça se passera à la
commanderie mais aussi dans les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines vous voyez ce lien est bien
pour toutes les informations n'hésitez
pas à cliquer et maintenant je vais donc
vous laisser improvisé écrire des vers
de la prose pourquoi pas paris saclay tv
c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite mais d'ici là restez
informé sur notre site peupe attiré
paris tiré saclay point fr à bientôt
[Musique]